[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing deathly hallows the death of
a weasley
and the twin brother that lived on we
all remember the tragic scene
it was the year 1998 and the battle of
hogwarts raged on
auras students and members of the order
of the phoenix alike
battled against lord voldemort and the
death eaters and there were casualties
serious casualties and like with most
epic battles and works of fiction
a character that we know and love
happened to be one of those casualties
in this case it was fred weasley it's
arguably one of the most tragic scenes
from the entire series
the air exploded they had been grouped
together harry ron
hermione fred and percy the two death
eaters at their feet
one stunned the other transfigured and
in that fragment of a moment
when danger seemed temporarily at bay
the world was rent apart
harry felt himself flying through the
air and all he could do was hold as
tightly as possible to that thin stick
of wood
that was his one and only weapon and
shield his head in his arms
he heard the screams and yells of his
companions without a hope of knowing
what had happened to them
and then the world resolved itself into
pain and semi darkness
he was half buried in the wreckage of a
corridor that had been subjected to a
terrible attack
cold air told him at the side of the
castle been blown away
and hot stickiness on his cheek told him
that he was bleeding copiously
then he heard a terrible cry that pulled
at his insides that expressed agony of a
kind neither flame nor curse could cause
and he stood up swaying more frightened
than he had been that day
more frightened perhaps than he had been
in his life and hermione was struggling
to her feet in the wreckage
and three redheaded men were grouped on
the ground where the wall had blasted
apart
harry grabbed hermione's hand as they
staggered and stumbled over stone and
wood
no no no someone was shouting
no fred no and percy was shaking his
brother
and ron was kneeling beside them and
fred's eyes stared without seeing
the ghost of his last laugh still etched
upon his face george and fred were the
closest of brothers
identical in every way and the kind of
twins that would spend every waking
moment with one another
their friendship was beautiful and that
is why i found it unusual
that we were never provided with much
info about what happened to george
after the death of his twin and brother
losing a friend is terrible
and losing a family member is terrible
so i can't imagine losing a twin
someone that is identical to you in
every way someone that you spend most
wicking moments with
the two were put through the ringer they
went through thick and thin together
so where does that leave george in a
2007 interview with bloomsbury
jk rowling was asked this very question
how is george getting along without his
twin
well i don't think that george would
ever get over losing fred which makes me
feel so very sad
however he names his first child and son
fred and he goes on to have a very
successful career
helped by good old ron the interview
also confirms that george continued
working at the business which he and his
brother had created
ron joined george at weasley's wizarding
weezers which became an enormous money
spinner
it comes as no surprise to me that
george rick continued the family
business
a business in the spirit of fun and
having a laugh is what fred would have
wanted
and continuing to work there would be
the best way to ensure that his spirit
lived on
furthermore in the documentary jk
rowling a year in the life
rolling dives into the weasley family
tree and mentions the following with
regards to george
a lot of readers ask me was george all
right and of course he wouldn't be all
right
would he that's the reality but i think
that he married angelina who was
actually fred's ex
maybe it's a bit unhealthy but they
think they would have been happy as
happy as he could be without fred
i think he really would have felt like
part of himself died
this is quite a sad and tragic answer
from rowling but i feel as though it's
also an accurate portrayal
of the truth yes life would go on for
george
but it would never be the same his
companion the person that he had shared
every moment with since childhood
was gone would he be happy again would
he experience joy again
yes of course but would george weasley
be changed forever
absolutely and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you